what's up doc ready to jam
the sequel to space jam is finally here
with lebron james bugs bunny
and the rest of the looney tunes taking
center stage
space jam a new legacy wouldn't be the
pop culture bonanza it is without its
visual effects
to celebrate the release of this sequel
let's look at some of the magic that
went on behind the scenes
let's get some birds in these seats
space jam a new legacy is set in the
digital world known as
the server verse a virtual playground
filled with hundreds of characters from
the warner brothers library
ranging from icons like batman and
scooby-doo to even r-rated characters
like the white walkers from game of
thrones
and the droogs from a clockwork orange
in order to create this server-verse
setting the vfx team had to challenge
themselves and go to lengths they've
never gone before
the film's headliner lebron james has
gone on record to say just how impressed
he is with the film's effects
i think the effects that we have
throughout the film are going to be the
greatest thing about the whole movie
that's quite the promise to make for
lebron producer ryan coogler who is no
stranger to franchise films directing
films like black panther
and creed was equally impressed with the
work of the film's animation team
spice jam really takes advantage of all
the cutting-edge filmmaking technology
the film's flashy and glorious chaotic
style makes coogler's statement
very easy to believe especially when you
consider just how much innovation went
into the first film
visual effects supervisor grady cofer
stressed in an interview
just how much work was put into making
the film look as
visually appealing as possible it takes
hundreds and hundreds of artists
building shots it took the animators and
vfx artists quite some time to finish
some of the shots
a shot such as this one featuring the
countless warner brothers icons
like the flintstones and king kong
rushing down the lush
animated landscapes of the server verse
easily took almost
a year of hard work to complete that's a
pretty hefty workload to say the least
the sequence following lebron falling
through the server-verse required some
practical work as james flies past
planets themed to game of thrones the
maltese falcon
dc comics and the wizard of oz wires
were attached to lebron to make it seem
like he was actually falling through the
server verse instead of just
standing in front of a green screen
classic
a major noticeable difference between a
new legacy and its 1996 predecessor
is the new legacy's mix of 2d and 3d
animation compared to the 1996 film's
strictly 2d stylings in the vein of the
comedy classic
who framed roger rabbit in fact ed jones
the special effects supervisor behind
roger rabbit
also served on the crew of space jam
further linking the two
films as for a new legacy one of the
biggest obstacles the animators faced
was designing 3d models for the classic
looney tunes characters and giving them
a look and feel that wouldn't betray
their original design or make them feel
overly modernized i look expensive
the team also wanted to make sure that
the film didn't feel too artificial
and wanted to really make the animated
tunes look as good as they possibly
could
this meant adding new features to these
characters that had never been done
before
in a featurette the film's animation
production designer devin crane said
we have all these textures and layers
and artistic complexities we really
wanted to make it film as handcrafted as
possible
the cg artists also found themselves
having to come up with new ways to bring
the world of warner brothers to life
cg supervisor abzuromi has said while
that process was to develop some new
tools to achieve that 2d aspect in the
3d world
lebron also faced some challenges
regarding the film's animation-heavy
setting
lebron was primarily acting against a
green screen and interacting with
characters that weren't actually there
on set
behind the scenes shots show lebron
acting opposite cardboard cutouts of
looney tunes characters
along with a crowd of extras dressed as
iconic characters from the warner
brothers library
another area that was new to lebron that
even michael jordan didn't have to take
part in
was to also be portrayed as a fully
animated character
alongside his live-action appearances
this was likely done because of his
extremely busy schedule playing for the
lakers as the movie was filmed over the
course of two years complete with the
live
action filming as well as all the
animation work the global pandemic was
another obstacle that the team faced
when working on the movie
like many movies much of the film's vfx
was done in post-production
but due to the circumstances provided
the animators and visual effects artists
all had to work from home even the voice
actors from the likes of veterans like
jeff bergman who provides his voice to
bugs bunny to superstars like zendaya
who voices lola bunny
had to record their lines from their own
home
i feel quite lucky to play such an
iconic
character at least voice her so i feel
pretty lucky bergman has said that this
was one of the first times in his career
as a voice actor
that he didn't get to meet the other
voice actors while recording his lines
who wouldn't be bummed about not getting
their chance to work with zendaya
hopefully he'll get his chance in space
jam 3.
i'm a cartoon what's up dad
space jam a new legacy was made on a
massive budget
of over 150 million nearly doubling the
original film's budget of 80 million
with how much technology has changed
over the years this shouldn't be
too surprising as trailers for the films
seem to be promising a true
looney tunes blockbuster sequel a space
jam sequel has been in the works for
quite some time
going through several phases one with
jackie chan titled
spy jam another featuring jeff gordon
titled
race jam and even a golf-themed sequel
headlined by tiger woods with a
supporting turn by michael jordan
ultimately the studio went with the
brendan fraser-led looney tunes back in
action
which proved to be a financial
disappointment
at the time wb was also working on a
direct sequel to space jam starring tony
hawk
which was eventually cancelled after the
poor performance of back in action
it wasn't until 2016 when the studio
decided to move forward with an official
sequel to space jam
when they felt they had the proper
technology and concept to make a true
follow-up
a reality lebron was coming off a
successful supporting turn in the amy
schumer comedy train wreck and had
recently signed a deal between his
production company
spring hill and warner bros and thus
space jam a new legacy
became a reality motion capture was one
of the key components used to enact some
of the film's basketball-themed stunts
which couldn't be performed in any other
way in particular
scenes required lebron to be thrown on
alley-oop
which required the crew to place the
camera behind the basket
the film's director malcolm d lee talked
about some of the difficulties filming
the scene saying
so it was a very small window to get the
shot so lebron caught it kind of high
and really just
threw his arm back and threw it down and
i jumped out of my seat
and i loved it because i wasn't really
trying to motivate him but it was kind
of a happy accident
of course a space jam sequel wouldn't
really be a true basketball film if
lebron didn't get to show off his
basketball skills on screen
and from the looks of it he'll continue
to prove to fans around the world
why he's one of the greatest at what he
does
i gotta say i think this is gonna be one
of the coolest movies people are ever
gonna see
it's clear that the cast and crew behind
space jam a new legacy had some
obstacles to face when creating the
film's
cg heavy setting but thanks to their
innovation and commitment to the film
the looney tunes are looking better than
ever for their reinvention of the 1996
classic are you excited to see space jam
a new legacy